dallas kykel goes to the mount for his
23rd start of the year looking for his
eighth win his era of four and a half
you look at the numbers not going to
strike out a lot of people not going to
walk a lot of people pitches it back up
the middle into center for a base hit
and that's the way our ball game begins
solid base hit the center by canna and
that'll bring up starly marte
there's a ground ball not hit terribly
hard they'll get one and that'll be it
no chance for two
good job by hernandez just to hang in
there and get that lead man for the
first out and that is trouble
and that will be
and out at first wow
i didn't think johan had a prayer to get
olson
but he did
runner at second two outs well this is
an outstanding effort because yuan had a
long way to come for this the pitch is a
grounder to anderson at short
easy throw over to first and feigl works
around a lead-off single the man they're
going to be facing is frankie montos
who's really kind of settled in over his
last few starts over his last three
starts 1.89 era
hit hard on the ground that's josh
harrison grabs it so one away so
hernandez with a one-out walk white sox
have their first base winner and that'll
bring up last year's mvp jose abreu
runner goes and it's a swing and a miss
gomez's throw is gonna be in time and
not picked cleanly by harrison so
hernandez is going to have a stolen base
and brayu strikes out here's a lloyd
jimenez one no pitch to him and he
swings and pops it up that's playable
near first olson is there right in front
of the bag straddling the foul line he
makes the catch and montas breaks out of
it here's matt chapman the third baseman
due to
chapman
deep to left field he's done it again
and that baby's gone the red hot matt
chapman is homered again
two homers saturday a homer on sunday
and a homer tonight one nothing is in
the second
right now they can't get him out now the
ace have a real shot base is loaded one
out infield back looking for two can is
up against kykel first pitch is line to
left and that's a base hit
harrison will score piscotti will stop
at third and it's two to nothing the a's
lead here's martay the one-two on the
ground kaikou
one two
safe
a man can run starling martay the only
thing on that you would ask yourself is
was he inside the baseline that's
something normally to take a look at but
he does beat the play here's austin
who's all for one three two count check
swing he went around
geico gets out of the inning allowing
only two it took a lot of work monkatta
walked to begin this second one toss has
walked two hasn't yet allowed a hit
man a good splitter and vaughn swings
and missed a second strikeout for
frankie montage was montas continued to
work his way through this this evening
here that pitch not only for strikes but
the put away gonna be big so one out
here is luis robert
not running and it's right down the
middle strike three call right down the
middle ring him up perfect pitch he must
have been looking for something else
debbie zavala will start things off the
catcher in the nine spot sebby zavala
off the end of the bat
and it's gonna drop and the sox have a
hit first one of the night leading off
the bottom of the third that'll bring
things to tim anderson
zavala is going to try to make third and
a good read he'll get in
and the throw got past the middlemen but
chapman backing it up
first and third nobody out now hernandez
now drive out of the center martay will
run it down
it'll be a sac fly as zavala scores
and the white sox on the board two to
one two to one game and now you've got
the double play in order with mr abreu
another three two anderson not running
this time swing gonna miss he ran a
fastball in on a brave jose abreu
strikes out for the second time a huge
strikeout for montas lead off man on for
the third straight inning
let's hit hard right to machine to
harrison and that's going to be a double
play so taylor made double play hit hard
right at the a short stop that's a
little blue light special two for the
price of one so two on two out the
batter is seti zavala
pitch to sebby
lined in the left that's a base hit
robert's gonna try to score the throw by
canna cut off they've got goodwin caught
it's going to be a tie game as goodwin
is tagged out and now to the baseline to
end the inning the sox get the run
on an rbi from sevi zavala to tie it at
two anderson's on with a lead-off single
here's cesar hernandez and he bunts
and it's a fair ball
chapman will throw to second tim just
got back in time
i thought chapman might let that ball
roll
but he decided to try to pick it up but
steve that there was so much spin on it
he just couldn't glove it cleanly so two
on nobody out and here is abreu's offer
with two strikeouts
and he got it a couple of good splitters
to a really good hitter frankie matos
gets a huge strikeout still first and
second now one away he'll bring up eloy
jimenez
tim's going to score
and the sox have the laid
a scorching liner
and chapman could only get a glove on it
and it's three to two
eloy can really put a charge into him
and robert's got a lead off single five
straight innings the white sex have had
their lead off man aboard so bring up
brian goodwin runner goes
strike called and luis is out
for now but he thinks he might have
gotten in and the white sox will check
with the video room they're gonna
challenge it
looks like he got to the back of the bag
and that throw is on the third base side
of second yeah i think he got in
absolutely safe by looking at it from
that angle
and that is the call
so they overturn it runner over at third
that's luis robert one out and that'll
bring up sebia zavala the safety squeeze
is not a bad play you bump up the first
base side and you can't possibly get
robert at the plate there's the bunt
toward first here comes robert he's
going to score
you called it partner
perfectly executed it's four to two
run bedded in a sacrifice
and a wonderful night for sebby he gets
the bunt down shortens up on the bat
make sure that
he does not pop it up it's four to two
greg kimbrough coming out for the 47th
time that'll bring the tying run to the
plate with nobody out swinging the miss
for the first out here comes lowry
lowry drives one
right center field and that one is off
the wall bounces up over the wall
and it'll be second and third and one
out so lowry with a ground rule double
and now base hit could tie it that is
his 21st double and now tony kemp is
going to run for it the batter is
chapman they'll play the infield back
the 3-2
3-2 anxiety and chapman chased two down
that was waiting for him on a two and
two equally as effective on the three
and two and he got him we talk about
lane changers this is from the right
lane all the way to the far left one so
now the a's need a two-out hit from josh
harrison another one-two here
[Applause]
craig kimbrell fired up nice escape job
in the eighth second and third one out
and he gives up nothing and it's still
4-2 white sox robert batting with one
out
[Applause]
he waits back and then is strong enough
to take it out of the ballpark by
a long way this is one strong man
three hits
the home run a stolen base three times
has scored the guy that's out there
looking for a little bit of a bounce
back get himself back on track here is
liam hendricks he became one of the best
closers in the game with the oakland a's
oh yes
a strikeout to start it so one out now
the pinch hitter mitch moreland
he went
two down
no chance on these sliders this slider
looks really sharp yeah this is as good
as we've seen it all year long two out
that'll bring up canna they're on their
feet here in the night
these [ __ ]
what a way to end it
as liam hendricks strikes out the side
and
the bow nice way to start this big four
game
series